Suppose you wrote an application called chocolate
chooser, that implements the chocolate back in
API using endpoints. The app ID for
chocolate chooser is choc-appID, the client ID
is 123choc. Now let's suppose someone else
writes an application called, let's say, devastating
desserts that uses JavaScript to access the
chocolate API. The app ID is dev-desserts, and
the client ID is 123devdes. And this devastating
desserts application is all about the UI, so
it doesn't have any back end API. So
now let's think about the API definition for
chocolate API in the chocolate chooser application. So
here we've got the API definition. The name
is chocolate API version V1. The scopes is
email. This basically mean, that we're going to be
using the user's email. It's up to you to tell us what would
the client ID be here. And go ahead and just enter a specific value.